so you were getting emotional in the
green room listening to Henry Rollins
talk about Putin you're about to quote
Chomsky like yes so he was
I just caught the end of my scent wet in
the green room and I like you know
everybody loves Henry Rollins right and
Henry that's why so good may be that
he's constantly grinding yeah but he was
doing that thing about Oh Putin do you
know there was a journalist who wrote a
book about him ended up dead Putin's a
bad guy he's a bad guy
as opposed to who well nobody you mean
he's definitely a bad guy right we all
agree that yeah
but I mean just because other people are
also bad guys doesn't negate his point
of Putin being a bad guy what he was
saying is just that it's very bizarre
that the Republicans these people that
were you know at the forefront of the
Cold War
these ones who really know I mean these
are the people that remember Khrushchev
banging on the desk you know saying
we'll bury you with with Kennedy these
people are now like they're whitewashing
Putin they're essentially like trying to
paint out Putin to be a good guy because
Trump is in this position where he's
trying to be friends with this guy so
well here's the court I wanted to send
you right so that whole thing if if
Nuremberg Laws were applied then every
post-war American president would have
been hanged
since says Noam Chomsky Putin kills
journalists we just torture ours so I
meet Chelsea Manning is a whistleblower
we took brocco bomb a torturer
so we have our president we have
Presidents and vice presidents who are
legit war criminals that walk around
today did a torture program okay so you
know Barack Obama who got a Peace Prize
and then he had a kill list that's right
a Peace Prize winner with a kill list
had drone kill II would you keep the
kill list next to the Peace Prize where
do you keep those threw things are they
anyway so this I that some of the people
that were killed were American citizens
with no due process no due process and
so it nobody has a problem with Trump
being buddy-buddies with Benjamin
Netanyahu who is a psychopathic maniac
who shoots who shoots with precision
medics who are trying to help people in
nurses
and journalists wait well some Israeli
troops right since Rayleigh troops do
that that's a really depressing thing
you know I had Abby Martin on and she
sort of illuminated that whole situation
I mean I really didn't know how bad it
was nor did she until she went over
there right and you know just
experiencing what it's like that the the
it's crazy that people that went through
the Holocaust that realized the cost of
dehumanizing an entire race of people
now are capable at least some of them
are capable of doing that to the
Palestinians yeah it's it's kind of
mind-blowing so wanted to hear and I
have friends who do that everyone's
doing this right everyone's getting
caught up in this hysteria that's why
there's a word called hysteria cuz it
happens and we're in one and you know
what I like is what Noam Chomsky said
about this Russia hysteria that's
happening he said if you care about
effects on our pristine elections which
he said very sarcastically he said if
you care about what's affecting our
pristine elections the Russia gate is
the last place I would look and the
first place he would look if you go
heard about foreign a control of or
influence on our government he said he
would look to Israel they're the ones
Benjamin Netanyahu came here and
addressed the joint session of Congress
without the permission or invitation of
the president remember when Obama was
president he did that he did that that's
a guy coming here to tell our guys how
to vote in direct defiance of our
president and everyone embraced him can
you imagine that Putin did that Putin
came to America and addressed our joint
session of Congress against the will of
the President so this idea that somehow
because Putin is a bad guy Trump
shouldn't have a good friendship with
them is BS the guys who are really
influencing our government here are
Benjamin Netanyahu Saudi Arabia but
Trump opened eight businesses in Saudi
Arabia during the election and no one
gives a crap about any of that stuff
because they're our friends Saudi Arabia
by the way just bombed at school today
school bus 29 kids dead so yeah I just
retweeted that from Sarab Diller so why
would they do that because they're in
Yemen there dude they're they're bombing
we're committing genocide in red Yemen
right now so we're helping Saudi Arabia
committed genocide in Yemen and the way
we're doing it is they're doing a thing
called siege warfare which is a war
crime and which in fact I just
prosecuted
somewhat a few months ago in at the
Hague for it so but well since we're
doing it and were the enforcers and
Saudi Arabia's out in the Human Rights
Council so it's assist everything's a
joke now right so we've we're past it
where it's at farce we're living in this
farce and so when I see a guy that I
love like Henry Rollins saying stuff
like Oh Putin's this special kind of bad
I just quote back Chomsky we're out
there we have nothing we have lit legit
war criminals just one presidency away
do you think he's a step removed from
that though I mean he'll Sasson eight
journalists in his own country right now
so right now we're trying to assassinate
Julian Assange right now are yes they're
trying to kill that guy yes they want at
that guy dead Hillary Clinton was so I
can't we drone that guy can't we kill
him yes she really did say that yeah she
really did say that after she just got
done killing Qaddafi and then laughed
about it yeah that that's we played that
several times yeah came we saw he died
hahaha the fact that any human being
would ever do that that she and by the
way the way he died that's some dark
[ __ ] they watch them they stabbed him in
the [ __ ]
right and there's a video of it I'm
stabbing him in the [ __ ] I standing
there just confused not knowing what
they're doing this guy's jamming a sword
up his ass have you seen the video oh I
have not seen oh my god it's awful you
want to see it no the video of them
capturing him is fascinating because
it's a guy who has lived with an iron
fist controlled these people been a
brutal dictator been a horrible monster
of a human being now all the scene these
rebels have captured him and they can't
believe they have I mean they're
shooting him and stabbing him and and
then eventually they have his body and
they parade his body around after
they've killed him but there's there's
there's video of him should look at it
for just for a moment cuz it's so
stunning to see him captured and alive
and can't believe that these rebels have
him that it's not even it's not even
like yeah you know I have seen video of
him captured and they look at his face
so I know what you're talking about just
the guys shoving but I did not i shoving
a knife up his ass